licht im dunkeln gesundheitsminister und
rk ii chef loben den rückgang der korona
zahlen warnen aber auch vor den
mutationen des virus land der extreme
während in rio die strände überfüllt
sind kollabiert in anderen teilen
brasiliens das gesundheitssystem
schwierige zeiten an der uni viele
studierende leiden unter einsamkeit und
müssen nach neuen wegen suchen ihr
studium zu finanzieren
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend in aalen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
kristin otto hat nachher in der sendung
den sport viel los bei uns guten abend
ein leicht positiver trend so fasst der
chef des robert koch-instituts lothar
wieler die korona lage in deutschland
zusammen
in diesen worten ist beides drin etwas
erleichterung und gleichzeitig sorge vor
dem was möglicherweise noch kommt im
detail sehen die zahlen heute so aus 17
1862 neuinfektionen in 24 stunden meldet
das rk ii
das sind gut 4500 weniger als am
vergangenen freitag ein trend das zeigt
auch diese kurve die täglichen
neuinfektionen im sieben tage schnitt
gehen wieder runter konstant hoch ist
weiter die zahl der menschen die an oder
mit kowitz sterben in deutschland
aktuell fast 860 menschen an einem tag
wo also stehen wir in dieser virus krise
der bericht von thomas reichert es ist
so eine art silberstreif die jens spahn
ein jahr nach dem ersten corona fall in
deutschland verkünden will
die infektionszahlen gehen runter
einerseits andererseits geschieht das
nur langsam und eben so langsam geht es
mit dem impfen voran sparen bittet um
geduld wir befinden uns zwar auf dem
höhepunkt der pandemie und gleichzeitig
haben wir den weg raus aus der pandemie
begonnen
ich weiß es geht viel nicht schnell
genug aktuell auch ich würde gerne
schneller mehr impfstoff verfügbar haben
durfte impfstoff bleibt knapp der
shutter und indes scheint zu wirken
an weihnachten lag die inzidenz noch bei
196 die deutschlandkarte war deshalb
tiefrot heute hat sie sich aufgehellt
denn die inzidenz liegt nun bei 115
allerdings die todeszahlen bleiben hoch
insgesamt sind seit beginn der pandemie
50.000 642 menschen in verbindung mit 19
gestorben das sind die offiziellen
meldezahlen und
das ist eine bedrückende für mich
skiunfalls produktion etwas entspannt
hat sich immerhin die lage den
krankenhäusern auf den intensivstationen
werden heute knapp 4800 patienten
betreut etwa 1000 weniger als anfang
januar
aber wir sind noch weit weg von einer
situation in der man von einer
entspannung sprechen kann man darf nicht
vergessen dass die patienten lange bei
uns auf den intensivstationen liegen
zumal virologen befürchten dass die
mutation des virus die in großbritannien
grassiert auch bei uns die fallzahlen
wieder nach oben treiben könnte wir
müssen das damit also jetzt nicht
weniger ernst nehmen sondern eher noch
ernster denn das ist garantiert dass ich
so eine mutante dann wirklich stärker
verbreitet wenn das so ist weiter an die
regeln halten fordert deshalb
bundespräsident steinmeier der von heute
an dazu aufruft ein licht ins fenster zu
stellen
zum gedenken an die krone opfer bei all
den positiven trends gibt es also eine
entwicklung wir haben's grad kurz gehört
die vielen wissenschaftlern und der
politik große sorge macht und das sind
die mutationen des virus soll zum
beispiel die neue britische variante
nicht nur ansteckender sein sondern
möglicherweise auch gravierendere
auswirkungen haben
auch deswegen ist es so wichtig exakt zu
wissen mit welcher art des erregers wie
es im einzelfall zu tun haben wie sich
also die mutationen verbreitet haben und
das schlüsselwort dazu heißt
sequenzierung das ist die betrachtung
des genetischen aufbaus einzelner corona
proben im labor
deutschland hat da eine menge
nachholbedarf marion geiger und anna
duda berichten
das labor von bios seien zwar in
ingelheim diese proben sind positiv auf
saas kopf 2 getestet
nun wird untersucht ob der wildtyp des
virus darin steckt oder neue varianten
motivieren
dafür wird das erbgut das genom des
virus sequenziert das kurbelt virus hat
30.000 tokio thiede also und die werden
nacheinander aus gelesen wie je wie
einzelne buchstaben in einem text in
einem buch und das machen wir und wenn
sich da etwas verändert hat dann können
wir das dann eben feststellen dass
corona viren mutieren ist normal denn
bei ihrer vermehrung in der menschlichen
zelle kann es zu kopieren fehlern kommen
sie verändern den genetischen code so
kann das virus noch gefährlicher werden
bei drei monaten scheint dass der fall
die mutierten viren aus südafrika
england und brasilien breiten sich
rasant aus und sind auch in deutschland
schon nachgewiesen worden
von diesen mutanten wissen wir dass sie
jedenfalls in teilfunktion gegen die
antikörper auch die antikörper die wir
durch die in fahrzeugen gegenstrategien
entwickeln und versuchen diesen
antikörper auszuweichen
das heißt wir werden möglicherweise uns
mit links streiten weiter optimieren und
anpassen müssen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir die genauen fähigkeiten
des virus und natürlich seine seine
zusammensetzung bezüglich des imf
antigens bisher wurde in deutschland nur
etwa jede tausendste positive probe
sequenziert in zukunft sind es
mindestens fünf prozent die ergebnisse
müssen an das robert koch institut
gemeldet werden und sollen endlich mehr
überblick bringen wo welche varianten
wie häufig auftreten
mit diesen daten könnte dann auch
seitens der politik früher reagiert
werden auf bedrohliche entwicklungen und
noch das zum thema impfstoffe mit
astrazeneca wird in der kommenden woche
ja voraussichtlich der dritte hersteller
eine zulassung für den europäischen
markt bekommen
das unternehmen musste aber jetzt schon
einräumen dass es lieferprobleme hat
konkret heißt das astra zeneca kann
zunächst nur weniger dosen bereitstellen
als eigentlich zugesagt
geschlossene grenzen in europa als
letztes mittel im kampf gegen die
ausbreitung des virus sind erstmal vom
tisch darauf haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs der eu auf ihrem video
gipfel geeinigt trotzdem wird das reisen
in teile europas schwieriger deutschland
verschärft ab übermorgen die einreise
regeln für 20 sogenannte hoch
risikogebiete darunter sind viele
europäische staaten
und wenn auch frankreich will muss einen
negativen pcr-test vorlegen
der muss innerhalb von 72 stunden vor
abreise gemacht worden sollen diese
pflicht gilt für alle reisen nach
frankreich die nicht zitat essentiell
sind
ausnahmen gelten unter anderem für
berufspendler der neue us präsident joe
biden hat seine nationale strategie
gegen das corona virus vorgestellt einen
rund 200 seiten dicken aktionsplan
er unterschrieb eine reihe von dekreten
zur bekämpfung der pandemie darunter
eine test und quarantäne pflicht für
einreisende in die usa
eine schnellere impfkampagne und mehr
gesundheitspersonal und dann gab es
einen bemerkenswerten momente im weißen
haus der führende us virologe anthony
fauci sprach darüber was der
machtwechsel in washington für die
wissenschaft bedeutet diese vorstellung
du kannst dir ans pult und sagen was du
weisst wissenschaftliche beweise und
fakten sprechen lassen
das ist ein wirklich so freien das
gefühl neben den usa ist brasilien im
moment eines der stärksten betroffenen
länder der welt rund 8,6 millionen
infizierte mehr als 210.000 tote das ist
die offizielle bilanz die dunkelziffer
dürfte weit höher liegen
und die zahlen steigen weiter zum teil
explosionsartig wie in der
amazonasmetropole manaus in den
krankenhäusern dort herrscht chaos es
gibt keine freien betten keinen
sauerstoff mehr eine dramatische
entwicklung die allerdings nicht überall
im land erkannt wird christoph rocker
war
es ist hochsommer in rio und es sieht so
aus wie immer aktuelle bilder
die strände sind voll erst auf den
zweiten blick fällt auf dass es kaum
touristen gibt aber sonst das leben geht
weiter sagen hier viel die anderen
jenseits der strände begraben ihre toten
so wie hier in sao paulo oder sie
betteln um einlass vor den
krankenhäusern wie in der
amazonasmetropole manaus wo das
gesundheitssystem kollabiert ist die
zahl der täglichen todesfälle hat sich
hier binnen eines monats fast
verzehnfacht ein man schnappt sterben
nach luft sein sohn filmteam und fleht
um hilfe an der verschlossenen tür
derzeit trauriger alltag in manaus die
menschen sterben das ist kein spiel das
ist kein spiel
hilfe wo bleibt der sauerstoff für die
krankenhäuser zu wenige betten und kein
sauerstoff
mehrere patienten teilen sich eine
flasche und auf der straße warten
hunderte auf sauerstoff um ihre
angehörigen wenigstens zu hause
versorgen zu können
zudem wird aus manaus eine neue mutation
des virus gemeldet noch was nicht sicher
wie gefährlich sie ist aber für
wissenschaftler ist sie die folge des
versagens der brasilianischen regierung
im umgang mit der pandemie
wenn man dem virus freien lauf lässt
dann führt das nicht nur zu einem
zusammenbruch des gesundheitssystems
mannschaft auch die perfekte umgebung
für mutationen präsident ball szenario
hat die krankheit von anfang an
heruntergespielt und zuletzt sogar
stimmung gemacht gegen die nur
schleppend anlaufenden impfungen weil
seine regierung auch hier spät gehandelt
hat die folge die korona zahlen in
brasilien rasen nach oben und die
proteste gegen den präsidenten werden
wieder lauter wir kommen nachher in der
sendung noch mal zum thema corona zurück
erst mal in die politik jetzt ist es
amtlich armin laschet ist der neunte
parteivorsitzende der cdu sein sieg bei
der online-abstimmung mussten die
delegierten des parteitags noch per
brief bestätigen
und jetzt ist dieses ergebnis da auf
laschet der keinen gegenkandidaten hatte
entfielen 83 35 prozent der
briefwahlstimmen verkündete der
wahlvorstand heute
damit ist die entscheidung des online
parteitags am vergangenen samstag bei
der sich laschet gegen friedrich merz
durchsetzte rechtskräftig die afg hat
heute klagen eingereicht und zwar gegen
den verfassungsschutz
unter anderem möchte sie ihm verbieten
lassen die partei als rechtsextremen
verdachtsfall einzustufen und darüber
öffentlich zu reden
fragen wir nach bei theo koll in berlin
theo was befürchtet denn die afg wenn
sie zum rechtsextremen verdachtsfall
würde nun sie befürchtet und es sicher
zu recht einen deutlichen
ansehensverlust für die gesamte partei
nicht zuletzt in diesem superwahljahr
schon bisher gelten ja zum beispiel die
landesverbände thüringen oder
brandenburg als verdachtsfall wenn das
jetzt für die ganze partei gelten sollte
dann könnte sie künftig mit sogenannten
nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
überwacht werden und das heißt konkret
dann könnten v leute in der partei
eingesetzt werden mitglieder könnten
beobachtet oder abgehört werden
letzteres allerdings nur mit genehmigung
einer dafür zuständigen kommissionen des
bundestages hier viele mitglieder der
afg sind öffentlich beschäftigte oder
beamte letzteren schreibt das
beamtengesetz jahr für den erhalt der
demokratischen grundordnung einzutreten
da wäre eine beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz zumindest ein
kritisches signal und für die afg in der
folge vielleicht auch ein
mitgliederverlust noch soll das rund
1000 seiten starke gutachten übrigens
beim bundesinnenministerium zur prüfung
liegen
denn um eine erfolgreiche klage der afg
dagegen auszuschließen muss natürlich
die rechtssicherheit einer solchen
entscheidung gewährleistet sein
danke schon auf berlin theo in leipzig
steht seit heute ein ehemaliger
bundeswehrsoldat der elite einheit ksk
vor gericht ihm werden unter anderem
verstöße gegen das
kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz und das
sprengstoffgesetz vorgeworfen
zu prozessbeginn legte der 45 jährige
ein geständnis ab er habe seine soldaten
bestmöglich ausbilden wollen und dafür
restbestände der bundeswehr in seinem
garten gelagert
bei einer razzia im vergangenen mai
waren neben waffen unter anderem auch
sprengstoff und mehrere tausend stück
munition
entdeckt wurden so jetzt geht es noch
einmal um corona beziehungsweise darum
wie sehr das virus unserem alltag
verändert in diesem fall den der rund
drei millionen studierenden in
deutschland seit zwei semestern ist fast
nichts mehr wie vorher unis geschlossen
nur noch online unterricht keine
praktika keine auslandssemester von
nebenjobs ganz zu schweigen
zur einsamkeit und geldsorgen kommt
immer häufiger das gefühl vergessen
worden zu sein sylvia bleßmann das tor
zur wissenschaft verschlossen die
gebäude der humboldt uni zu seit monaten
kennt hier um kontakt nur noch distanz
lehrer daheim allein am computer für uns
junge menschen fällt halt eigentlich
alles weg was wir so tun pandemie
bedingt sind wir natürlich alle
irgendwie eingesperrt und könnte das
schon von einem geklauten jahr sprechen
ein bis drei jobs hat er schon verloren
nachtclub galerie und agentur machten
dicht nun ist er wieder auf arbeitssuche
denn sein antrag auf coroner nothilfe
für studenten wurde gerade abgelehnt
andere wie eure gute wollen endlich
fertig werden aber fehlende praktika und
immer wieder verschobene prüfungen
verlängern die studienzeit sie fühlt
sich wie im stau
für mich vergessen von der politik von
meiner uni von von der gesellschaft auch
so ein bisschen weil kein wert
daraufgelegt wird was mit uns gerade
passiert in der ganzen panne situation
seit einem jahr trete ich jetzt nach
fast acht jahren studium komplett auf
der stelle weiß nicht wie es weitergeht
wieder abschluss ist wie es beruflich
weitergeht zum frust über verlorene zeit
kommen lichtblicke in kleinen
gemeinsamen digitalen projekten hier
entstand ein film über die analyse von
tabletten digitale lehre verlangt
kreativität eingehen brauchen wir nur
den rahmen geben und den studierenden
die chance geben zu zeigen was in ihnen
steckt eine herausforderung der sich die
studierenden im ersten semester gern
stellten um zumindest etwas austausch
mit anderen kommilitonen zu haben
andere der mann dann später vielleicht
die chance hat und es bleibt dann
irgendwann zu arbeiten denn technik
tippen sind offenbar die kleinsten
hürden dieser digitalen studienzeit
urteil heute in einem fall der sich
eingebrannt hat im oktober 2009 10
entdeckten polizisten in der nähe von
london
die leichen von 39 vietnamesischen
migranten in einem lkw
sie sollen menschenhändler teils mehr
als 10.000 euro bezahlt haben um nach
großbritannien geschleust zu werden
die vier hauptangeklagten wurden jetzt
zu langen haftstrafen verurteilt andreas
stamm berichtet er sei lkw-fahrer und in
seinem hänger seien viele menschen die
nicht mehr atmen der notruf des menschen
schmugglers im oktober 2009 10 das ende
einer horrorfahrt 39 menschen aus
vietnam sind tot
am mittag verkündet ein gericht in
london das urteil die vier
hauptangeklagten einer schleuserbande
erhalten haftstrafen zwischen sieben und
20 und 13 jahren
diese verbrecher haben ihr geld mit dem
leid anderer verdient sie waren sich der
gefahren bewusst
sie transportierten die opfer auf eine
art die man keinem tier antun würde die
methode der menschenhändler immer gleich
ein laden in nordfrankreich per fähre
geht es über den belgischen hafen
zeebrügge ins südenglische per flieht
sie erhalten bis zu 15.000 euro pro
geschmuggelter personen zum verhängnis
wird 39 menschen diesmal die gehe der
schmuggler sie packen doppelt so viele
wie üblich in den kühlcontainer fotos
zeigen kratzspuren versuche dem tod
durch ersticken oder hitzschlag zu
entkommen
eins der opfer die 19-jährige putin nun
sie wollte in england geld verdienen
damit die familie schulden zurückzahlen
kann
der prozess hat aufgezeigt wie ein
skrupelloses geschäft funktioniert das
klare urteil bringt etwas trost für die
familien noch der menschenhandel in
europa so experten ging und geht genauso
weiter
ja das ist schwierig jetzt rüber zum
sport zu kommen aber so ist das wenn
dieser sendung wir machen einen klaren
strich und christin macht hier weiter
viele traurige männer zuerst große
enttäuschung bei den deutschen
handballern denen droht das vorzeitige
wm-aus in ägypten sind nun auf
schützenhilfe angewiesen und müssen nach
der bitteren niederlage gegen spanien
ihre letzten beiden hauptrunden spiele
gewinnen krafttraining am tag danach zur
ablenkung aber der blick zurück bleibt
schmerzhaft sie haben trotz rückstand
gekämpft mit drei toren geführt aber in
den entscheidenden momenten wieder nicht
getroffen
das viertelfinale ist außer reichweite
jetzt hilft nur noch das prinzip
hoffnung
es geht jetzt auch darum auch mit der
mannschaft auch dieses turnier positiv
zu beenden
trotzdem ist es so dass man jetzt
natürlich mit immer anderen auge darauf
dass polen ungarn spiel gucken hört von
routinierten spanien lernen und das
positive aus der niederlage rausziehen
ein erster schritt muss ein sieg gegen
brasilien seien mehr und diese partie
morgen abend live hier bei uns im zdf
20.15 bereits heute zur gleichen zeit
der auftakt der fußball bundesliga
rückrunde
das pressebüro borussen duell langsam
ein spiel mit brisanz thomas cook ja und
deshalb sicher auch heute ein nettes
fußballspiel obwohl die belastung hoch
ist weil es keine winterpause gibt und
es für beide bereits das dritte spiel
innerhalb von sieben tagen sein wird
aber das sind 2 auf augenhöhe
2 die in der hinrunde ein paar probleme
mit sich geschleppt haben im moment
platz sieben gegen platz vier
der bvb hat das problem seiner
unerklärlichen zwei gesichter und
borussia mönchengladbach die späten
gegentore die viele viele punkte
gekostet haben probleme die beide heute
lösen wollen nachher gleich hier danke
thomas knie
die streift der klassiker im alpinen
weltcup heute vorzeitig abgebrochen nach
einigen zwangspausen durch stürze der
abfahrt sieg ging an den schweizer
wertvoll
nach vier zweiten plätzen des bioabfalls
zum ersten mal der schlechte in
kitzbühel
doch auch dann muss der schweizer einen
schweren sturz vom landsmannes grün will
mit ansehen
wer nach dem zielsprung kopfüber auf die
piste breit zuvor war us-fahrer ryan
cochrane siegl in der traverse gestürzt
beide werden mit dem helikopter
abtransportiert wie durch ein wunder
ohne lebensgefährliche verletzungen
bester deutscher ist andreas sander auf
einem starken fünften platz
morgen die nächste abfahrt auf der
streif das traditionelle
hahnenkammrennen ja und wintersport
morgen den ganzen tag ja im zdf nämlich
genau ja sehr gut fielen dann christin
gern das auf und ab beim wetter geht
weiter nachdem sturm wird jetzt kälter
dann kommt schnee aber erst kommt katja
horneffer mit mehr details heute-journal
empfehle ich ihnen natürlich in der
fussball halbzeit um 21 uhr 15 mit der
kollegin marietta slomka
wir sind natürlich auch am wochenende
für sie da und freuen uns drauf aber
erst den namen des gesamten teams in
allen einen sehr angenehm
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das steuern
der central tief liegt gerade über
südnorwegen und das hat eingerannt tiefs
produziert 1 sich jetzt gerade weiter
richtung schweden aber auch hier in
mitteleuropa gibt es einige teams die
uns am wochenende häufig schnee bringen
denn auch schon in dieser nacht geht der
regen in dem er nach osten zieht immer
mehr in schnee über oberhalb von 300 bis
500 meter etwa machen sie sich also auf
gefährlich glatte straßen gefasst bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus vier
und minus zwei grad und morgen liegen
dann die höchsttemperaturen in
deutschland zwischen null und sieben
grad und damit ist es dann doch deutlich
kälter als zuletzt und so fällt morgen
vor allen dingen der osthälfte noch
schnee und schneeregen und hier im
nordstau des erzgebirges können 10 bis
15 cm neuschnee zusammenkommen
zwischen nordfriesland und dem alpenrand
gibt es einen recht freundlichen
streifen da kommt auch mal kurz die
sonne zum vorschein
nachmittags dann aber kommen im
südwesten schon die nächsten schnee
regen wolken an und dieser schnee
breitet sich dann am sonntag weiter nach
nordosten aus es bleibt also glatt auf
den straßen bei höchsttemperaturen
zwischen minus ein und plus vier grad
und in der neuen woche geht es
winterlich weiter mit schnee besonders
im süden und am mittwoch wird es dann
von westen allmählich wieder etwas
milder schönes wochenende